how you been - Calvin out there here you
go you ready there we go do you miss
that sound a little bit I do i watch the
game one time with TV and I didn't
realize how reckoning that sound was I
guess I gotta go for five years but in
the game of TV's not as fun
any good vacations in the offseason no
not anything special definitely just
hung out with the friends went fishing
with high school coaches and my brother
and I was probably as fun and I'm as
peaceful as I got oddest place you've
been recognized well that's a great
question I probably say I guess the
bathroom I mean at a restaurant or
something it's probably been the hottest
and the most awkwardest meeting or
fanning it happens in the bathroom and
then they forget to wash their hands and
then they want to shake your hand and
think it's a little I make sure I make
sure they wash how was camp different
this year I mean the easiest way to said
has just been the number of reps I've
gotten um last year in camp I was
getting maybe at most six foot up today
so now I mean I was taking every every
rapid camp and that was definitely the
most helpful part but as well I was just
running out to practice and leaving it
open to the fans not really being my
name being screamed a lot last year to
the way of a screen mishit was pretty
fun and exciting as well so it's changed
it a little bit best advice you got last
year through this whole process was
given to you by who got tons of the
great advice um I can't remember exactly
who said it but uh someone told me just
to be myself don't go trying to be some
other quarterback or the next this guy
the next tag guy I just continue to be
myself I stay humble to never forget
where I can come from and that's
definitely goes goes without my guess
noticed how hard it is to do that I
guess it would playing with the Dallas
Cowboys and just as market so as
important advice well you did it you
accomplished it and to be a
rafted where you were to be put in that
spotlight I mean I don't know how you
kept your composure I mean but you did
it so I don't know if it was what your
mom gave you but you know there was
something instilled in you that you were
able to process this do you have any
idea how you did it
oh yeah definitely see my mom I'm gonna
just remembering exactly where I came
from not just where I was a year ago but
where I was ten years ago where I was
when I was just a little boy and
everything that I've been through I'm
not taking anything for granted
and just being thankful staying within
the moment something that I try to make
sure I do no matter if it's in a game
and it's worrying about just this third
down or if it's being on being on a
phone call with you and making sure that
I'm worried about this is just making
sure I control the things I can control
and the rest will take care of itself
who'd you root for growing up the Dallas
Cowboys no you did not really yes I did
okay yeah I did my dad's a huge Dallas
Cowboys fan so I I grew up really not I
would say not having a choice but he
gave us all choices because my other
brothers more tablet science but just
kind of rolled with my dad and it's all
panned out explain to the audience how
big a Tim Tebow fan you were or are oh
yeah when I was young I mean I was a
huge Tebow fennell Mississippi State to
play at the same offense that Tim Tebow
played under more number 15 for Tim
Tebow to me he's arguably one of the
greatest or if not the greatest college
football player him and Reggie Bush so I
mean just the fact of everything that he
did and how tough he was at the
quarterback position to me he changed
the quarterback position in college to
being a tough guy for some offenses and
especially that spread offense to
running the ball as much as me and him
dead that just allowed me to kind of
take similarities from his leadership in
his game is your dog named Tebow I had a
dog named Tebow when I was in high
school and unfortunately I had to move
out and we had and I'm giving it away to
a family friend so I don't have people
anymore but you remember when you were
at Mississippi State you got those
comparisons you're sort of a
right-handed Tim Tebow and and in
college that sounds like a great
compliment but in the pros
I were they still labeling you is a
Tebow like and would that translate into
the NFL yeah they they definitely were
as I was going into the draft process
and I was going through everything I was
still getting the Tim Tebow label and as
you said it's a it's a huge honor to be
getting those recognitions and
comparisons when you're in we're in
college but as you moved over to the pro
level I was kind of a NOC so at that
point I was just trying to make a name
for myself and show coaches how much I
knew about the game and just my game was
different
he's dak Prescott Cowboys quarterback
joining us on behalf of DIRECTV's NFL
Sunday Ticket all right let me see how
you do it lately
let's see how good you are with this
pitch tell us why we need to get Sunday
Ticket if we don't already have it oh
yeah I mean Sunday Ticket it's important
I mean we've they've been the home with
DirecTV DirecTV has been the home of
Sunday Ticket for 20 years and I grew up
watching all the commercials and being a
huge fan of it
so I know there's kids and everybody out
there I don't want to miss any game
don't want to miss any play or their
favorite team you can do that with the
Sunday tickets the one and only place
that you get every live out-of-market
game so you don't have to miss me player
two Cowboys play with the red zone
channel you don't have to miss a
touchdown and the new the new channel is
the fantasy zone which allows players to
get up-to-the-minute update on the
scores and the points and you just don't
necessarily have to have a satellite to
watch DIRECTV as you can get the NFL dot
TV and watch it on the tablet a phone
Xbox Playstation preferably for me so
it's definitely important I know I get
to watch me play okay now were you
reading that or did you memorize that no
no reason here okay all right all right
well then that's that's Peyton Manning
ask right there those are better
comparisons who do you expect to be your
running back week one just I know
they'll make the right decision yeah
it's kind of a tough situation because
you're trying to prepare your offense
there how do you do that
I mean we have a great offensive line
that does a good job of giving any
running back who who's in there
the opportunity to make plays I mean I
was the expression he's a great Eclair
so we've been practicing as if Zeke's in
there was the same way we're going to
practice and another renovation is
rotating so nothing's changed
I will let that old take care of itself
but we're gonna worry about the Dallas
Cowboys with the players we have right
now did you exchange any jerseys with
any players during the year um yes I did
I exchange with a college teammates
Fletcher Cox Preston Smith actually a
Jew look at this Jackson I and the Pro
Bowl and was fortunate enough to to be
there but as well exchange with Drew
Brees Patrick Peterson and I have plans
to exchange what other guys nice okay
Congrats on the success so far I'll
leave you with this I Dec thanks for
joining us and good luck thank you the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience